[Applaudissements]
cadeau un quart d'heure sans fil sur
jean luc mélenchon d'abord et après bien
sûr on parlera des miss france
jean luc mélenchon et son parti la
france insoumise dont il est député et
président ont fait les gros titres à la
suite des perquisitions menées au
domicile de l'ancien candidat à la
présidentielle et dans les locaux de son
mouvement
ça fait les gros titres de toutes les
chaînes info on a vu ça tournait en
boucle forcément on vous a préparé un
petit récap et c'est vrai que les vidéos
sont folles mais franchement les vidéos
encore ce matin encore je t'aime c'est
vraiment rude
regarde c'est une scène surréaliste à
laquelle les internautes ont pu assister
hier en direct sur facebook
jean luc mélenchon figure de proue du
parti de gauche la france insoumise a
filmé en direct la perquisition dont il
faisait l'objet
ne touchez pas ma personne est sacrée je
suis parlementaire et pour nous en
convaincre
voilà chez moi mélenchon avec une
écharpe tricolore
des dizaines de représentants de l'ordre
public sont entrés chez lui pour
rassembler des pièces à conviction dans
le cadre de deux enquêtes préliminaires
la justice le soupçonne d'avoir utilisé
des fonds destinés à l'emploi
d'assistants parlementaires européens
pour le financement de collaborateurs de
son parti une seconde enquête est quant
à elle dirige et autour de possibles
irrégularités de comptes de campagne de
la france insoumise
jean luc mélenchon s'est également
échappée avec les forces de l'ordre aux
portes des locaux de son parti
quelques heures plus tard à l'assemblée
jean luc mélenchon a profité des
questions au gouvernement pour
interpeller le premier ministre edouard
philippe raisonnable ça veut dire plus
interoute solidaire de france ne
dépareille avant de réagir à cette
affaire ce matin chez jean jacques
bourdin
pourquoi je vais regretter un
comportement qui vous êtes monsieur
bourdin on m'interdit d'entrer dans
siège de mon propre mouvement est chez
moi qui vais regretter
alors selon vous les politiques ont-ils
le droit de perdre leur sang froid
alors c'est vrai que jean luc mélenchon
allez vous répondez quoi qu'il prend
garde oui non vous allez nous dire c'est
vrai que jean luc mélenchon bref c'était
voilà c'est extrêmement chaud à ce qu'on
a vu
alors les avis sur twitter sont assez
partagés on est 8 de notre ami julien
courbet la politique pour les nuls règle
3 quand un politique de droite ou de
gauche se fait perquisitionner c'est une
injustice ou un règlement de compte
quand c'est un land bas c'est normal
d'ailleurs on n'en parle pas et ils sont
des centaines chaque jour voilà il ya
plein de gens qui ont réagi à guillaume
tc qu'on aime beaucoup on peut tout
perquisitionné sauf ma liberté de pensée
avec une photo voilà il a fait encore un
montage photo voilà un magnifique l'iut
c alors est-ce que voilà est-ce que vous
avez été choqué aussi par celle ci
rappelle péter les plombs
qu'est ce que vous vous êtes là pour
rappeler aux téléspectateurs vous êtes
groupe et nicolas sarkozy sanaa plus
pété les plombs c'est très dommage parce
que moi je partage pas les idées de
mélenchon chacun ses idées mais c'est le
dernier tribun romantique un talent fou
dans ses discours roland talent fou
darden dans ses campagnes etc et tout
d'un coup pourquoi ils gâchent comme ça
c'est à lens mais parce que quand on
leur présente alors il s'agit alors je
vais vous montrer la belle héroïne de la
république on va voir la vidéo
oui prononce la phrase personne ne me
touches masterson ma personne et sacré
je suis parlementaire ces saletés
nations après des mois
regardez ce mec que tout
me touchait pas monsieur vous n'avez pas
le droit de me toucher
ça c'est le procureur qui dit que je
sais pas quoi personne ne me touche ma
personne est sacrée je suis
parlementaire et pour vous en convaincre
et vous terminez bien comprendre qui je
suis voilà c'est moi mélenchon avec une
écharpe tricolore
je n'ai peur de personne ces gens là
peuvent envoyer à ma maison les locaux
de mon parti et de mon mouvement et ne
font pas peur alors et on verra la vidéo
après ce qui s'est passé ce matin sur
bfm d'aller voir et il a continué alors
vous vous pensez que les politiques ont
le droit de perdre leur sang froid vous
êtes plutôt pour jean luc mélenchon
trouvez que c'est normal je le défends
totalement d'accord alors on peut
discuter d'une phrase au dos mais sur le
fond la perquisition chez lui il a
l'impression qu'on violait son matériel
connaît depuis la fin des années 80
quand il était élu dans l'essonne il a
toujours été comme ça c'est un
méditerranéen impulsé ça forge acquis
les anti système
on ne le changera pas c'est pour ça que
les gens l'aiment ou le déteste mais il
ne peut pas se renier il est lui même
jusque dans cette vidéo là donc je le
défends alors ils sont victimes ni
dégâts qui veut dire des limites qu'il
ne faut pas franchir quand on représente
la république
autre exemple de la france la hoya un
responsable de droite qui me dit qu'ils
m'envoient si nicolas sarkozy avait eu
le même comportement que jean luc
mélenchon personne ne lui aurait trouvé
des excuses c'est une honte est ce que
vous êtes d'accord excessive un
justiciable nous autour de la table et
on n'aurait malheureusement une
perquisition à notre domicile devant
ferro et cinq ans si on s'oppose au
procureur si on bouscule les portables
ont fini avec les menottes et on est
bien sûr davud donc pardonnez-moi louis
xiv disait l'état c'est moi lui dit la
république c'est moi il se prend pour
qui
alors que jean michel valette mais
jamais oui on peut perdre son sang froid
quand c'est pour une cause juste là les
pas du tout parce que c'est une
perquisition dans les riffs illégal qui
est fait dans les règles
ils se croient au dessus des lois voilà
contrairement au système tvq qui lui
fait croire qu'il pourfend voilà et
voilà qu'en seine conclut séquence
exceptionnelle lui c'est son système de
communication et son système politique
il faut tout le temps être au devant la
scène et c'est bien fait pour lui c'est
lui que c'est filmé et ça avec lui est
retombé dessus c'est y ait une balle
dans le pied tout seul c'est des images
alors alors attention qui sont assez
d'accord avec jean luc mélenchon voulzy
il a tenant il a tenu à s'exprimer à
l'assemblée nationale seulement dès que
jean luc mélenchon crie un peu trop
voilà ils ont trouvé le moyen de se le
faire taire parce que jean luc mélenchon
c'est vrai qu'il est coutumier du fait
d'avoir des petites crises et regarde l
assemblée nationale comment ça se passe
il ya juste une volonté de salir
monsieur macron est un petit personnage
madame belloubet garde des sceaux vous
avez connu autrefois il ya longtemps
comme votre ami ce que vous êtes en
train de faire est une honte
nos amis plusieurs ont été jetés à terre
voilà comment nous avons été traités et
ces gens se concerter entre eux ensuite
pour dire que nous les aurions de
menacer ou insulter nous n'avons
insulter ni menacer personne
ce n'est pas normal d'en pêcher des
parlementaires en écharde de rentrer
dans leurs propres locaux
ça suffit monsieur macron ceci est
encore une république à une démocrate y
est je ne suis pas un passant dans la
rue je suis le président du groupe
alors cyril c'était ce matin après bfl
où il ne s'est jamais offusqué des
perquisitions chez les autres j'avais
quand c'est lui en revanche oui mais
pour qui se prend celui l'anarchie c'est
refuser le système lui c'est pas
d'anarchie qui se croit au dessus du
système alors ça qui est très dangereux
la perquisition c'est au moment où les
locaux de la france a soumises ont été
perdus
jean luc mélenchon une partie des
membres de la france insoumise voilà ont
un peu perdu leur sang froid face aux
policiers
complètement regarder la crise pas d'où
ça policiers de cette image qui peut
être cette image qu'on va voir qui est
qui est complètement folle juste avant
géraldine maillet vous vous défendez
jean le jean luc mélenchon non je le
défends pas j'ai dit qu'il a toujours
fait ça en fait c'est le chefresne c'est
l'acteur studio alors ils entrent
vociférations victimisation complotite
ils se trompent paysans fait il veut pas
du tout dire des choses intéressantes il
veut juste une quantité de choses et
juste occupé le terrain et qu'on parle
de lui et d'ailleurs bilan il a raison
il a réussi puisqu'on parle plus de mick
d'allocutions de alors ça vous c'est
vrai qu'on parle plus de lui que de
l'intervention du chef de l'état y est
alors être justement je vous montrer des
images
est-ce que vous avez été choqué vous par
ces images parce que c'est vrai qu'on se
disait repasser en boucle nos bureaux en
préparant les missions vous les avez vus
fabienne non alors vous allez voir les
ai vus biyouna oui cd&v alors choqué
chaud aux réflexions très heureusement
le regard des jeunes et policiers
républicains la république se voir
[Musique]
pousser la porte camarades
alors ta foi puisque jean lapierre qui
viennent chez moi
huit personnes dont trois armées allait
à fait moi pour voir papa s'en voit des
policiers comme ouais franchement bravo
mais là c'est vrai que là c'est vraiment
très non mais vraiment du policier et
zeljko travaux ce que tu dis excuse moi
mais là on voit bien que ça à bouchon
parce que moi je lis que c'est un
bouffon c'est que là encore d'un
interview à voici la chronique à petit
bonhomme etc
et quand ils le croisent dans la rue par
hasard ah oui ah non j'ai jamais dit
stein 25 kg qui lui fait la bise rares
et économie moi ce qui me choque le plus
c'est que c'est vrai que c'est un
personnage nous n'en ai fait ça mais on
va on va on va où on va vainqueur en
garde à vue on n'a jamais vu avec saddam
et c'est ça qui me choque eagle
et moi je trouve que être achevée très
bien mais la meilleure façon de se
défendre contre quand on veut tu as un
sommet dans les cas de la république là
il est en dehors du cadre et c'est ça
qui me choque le plus alors il ya eu il
ya eu une annonce et jean jacques
bourdin donc je voulais dit ce matin les
hanches les échanges étaient très très
tendue avec jean jacques bourdin
on aurait dit un combat de boxe ou liste
jean jacques bourdin comme à son
habitude n'a pas ménagé son invité
regardez c'est parti il vous roule dans
la farine
vraiment il me rend fier alors d'accord
regarder la caméra
non non vous bourdin vous allez vous
calmer parce que je n'ai jamais vu ça
bon ça d'accord oui vous allez vous mais
les mots vous en voyez je vais non mais
vous plonger là je ne bousculerait pas
policier oui d'accord
écoutez on verra ce que vous ferez dans
ce moment là parce que vous faites le
matin c'est précieux
est ce que vous regrettez voilà une
vérité pas je ne parle pas qu'ils savent
je peux regretter si vous êtes
journaliste vous vous faites je service
a duré vingt ans que vous regrettez à
cette heure nous attend mais oui police
on ouvre la porte on vous montre le truc
huit personnes chez moi dont certains
sont armés avec des gilets pare-balles
des fois que je sais pas quoi je les
agressent à conques rayon hein c'est
juste un intellectuel un militant
politique c'est tout j'ai rien volé je
suis un méditerranéen
je bouge beaucoup de bras et vous aussi
et les yeux et le reste et je me fâche
alors jacques jacques juste voilà vous
êtes un communicant vous allez les plus
grands combien contre 11 et qu'est ce
que vous dites voilà jean luc mélenchon
essaie de faire quoi il s'est tu
rattraper mais c'est eux les toujours il
essaie d'attaquer pour essayer d'oublier
est obligé comme comme tu l'as dit très
justement c'est quand même lui avec
excès ouais et donc il est obligé de il
le pense profondément
je pense qu'il est sincère ouais le plus
important pour un politique c'est la
sincérité alors bon il a dérapé ce ne
serait pas acceptée mais on peut lui
pardonner à cause de sa sincérité parce
qu'il est ça depuis toujours mais c'est
pas comme ça qu'on devient président de
la république vous dites qu'il est comme
ça depuis toujours on a récupéré nuages
couvrent ap les quantités étaient pris à
un cheminot il interpellait à périgueux
en marge d'une manifestation
regardez pourquoi tu me parles comme ça
pourquoi on ne respecte pas juste ma vie
à vous défendre
ma vie mais quand on vote contre les
directives européennes voient personne
nous fîmes la caf vous énervez mon
personnage était mon ennemi c'est sa
facture par sanofi leur va voir les mecs
de droite c'est eux qui vous ennuie dans
la merde c'est le ps qui vous a mis dans
la merde voilà donc il est coutumier du
fait j'en ai d'autres en 2011 je vous
montre une image dans un instant mais
continuer alors vous est ce que les
politiques pour le droit de perdre leur
sang froid c'est la question qu'on vous
pose déchiré vous répondez gilles verdez
voulait réagir at oui et c'est vrai que
là il est sincère et l'uimm quand
géraldine big c de la communication ici
on fait pas de politique mais ça me
hérisse parce que il est vraiment
lui-même il est au complétistes tu vas
des contrées partout donc c'est normal
que ça te plaise ya ya ya un ami
sébastien proyart de mehdi handicap tu
m'envoies un sms très drôle qui me dit
mélenchon est un showman au top
ces hologrammes n'ont pas chômé hier
voilà ces hologrammes
oui alors gilles vous disais moi je dis
que mélenchon il a le droit d'être comme
ça lorsque mais parce que c'est vous
c'est nous seuls deux heures du matin
chez lui il ne le supporte alors il est
pas en dehors des lois la plaît s'il
vous plaît dit là il ya le premier
ministre qui a réagi voilà edouard
philippe
voilà sur cette affaire regardez images
que j'ai vues étaient d'une très grande
violence d'une très grande violence à
l'égard de fonctionnaires de police qui
exerçaient leur mission des
perquisitions dans des formations
politiques
c'est déjà arrivé des mises en cause de
personnalités qui ont un rôle politique
ou qui ont eu un rôle politique
c'est déjà arrivé ça n'est jamais
agréable mais j'observe monsieur le
député que tous ceux qui ont été mis en
cause et qui parfois ont vu je le
reconnais leur honneur mis en cause tout
cela tout cela me semble-t-il ont
systématiquement garder à l'égard des
forces de police et à l'égard de
l'institution judiciaire
un très grand calme
alors voilà alors on voit il ya jean luc
mélenchon dans l'hémicycle bien sûr
voilà et c'est vrai que alors voix
petite question que je vous pose et
parce que j'ai entendu gilles verdez
dire voilà à 7 heures du matin quand on
arrive c'est quelqu'un on peut perdre
son sang froid
est-ce qu'il n'a pas réagi comme un
citoyen lambda voilà jean luc mélenchon
et est-ce qu'il a le droit de le faire
c'est la marne alors alors alors déjà
moi je suis scandalisé par ce qu'il a
fait parce que déjà on 17 heures du
matin une vraie perquisitions ces six
heures c'est par cette heure après ils
l'ont laissée ils ont fait des cadeaux
les flics ils n'ont pas mis les menottes
normalement quand une perquisition si tu
fais de la rébellion times note
il nous dit nous dit à nous d'aider
tandis les droits les devoirs quand tu
es français la république qui sorte de
république
tu as des droits et des devoirs moi si
je roule à 52 kilomètres heure la
patrouille à mareth au lieu de 50
ils vont dire d'ouvrir mon coffre je
vais pas faire de rébellion si tu fais
pas de rebellions ça se passe très bien
une percussion ça m'énerve parce qu ils
nous envoient faire des manifestations
république qui dit le peuple paie mais
il se prend au dessus du peuple fait
comme nous après en or en ce sens on
s'étonne parce que les gens ils sont
dégoûtés de la politique pourquoi parce
qu'il est peu au dessus des lois jeans
et il a le droit il éclaire nation on
n'a pas envie de rentrer chez lui bien
sûr que si qu'on a droit en france tu es
mis en perquisition tu peux contester
nous quand on a une amende il faut
d'abord la payer et après on comptera là
il aurait dû faire la gueule après qu'on
paye ainsi n'est pas contente de fonte
est après
au total
la maison
pas entendu dire ici autour de la table
c'est jean-luc moyens mais toujours été
comme ça alors m nicolas demorand le
recevez en 2011 sur europe 1 et le ton
est très vite monté entre regarder mon
cher demorand figurez vous que j'ai été
élu comme député européen
oui monsieur demorand j'ai été élu deux
fois conseiller général pas vous alors
remballer votre vos grands airs ce que
pas loin de me parler comme cesc en 2002
du marché ce n'est pas parce que vous
êtes derrière deux pas du tout mais
ouais mémoire voire les mois poliment
mais je vous parle très joli vent du
peuple et je les tiens élu au suffrage
direct formidable vous décidiez que les
élus du suffrage indirect sont les
sénateurs voulaient méprise est ce qu'en
2012 vous allez aller devant le peuple
eh ben je l'espère je l'espère ne serait
ce que pour vous pouvez le bec
quand même fait une perquisition chez
toi aussi t'as rien à te reprocher tu
les laisses rentrée ils fouillent ska si
tu ne l'as pas rentrer c'est que tu as
quelque chose qui va pas moi il vient de
revenir chez moi
fouillez ils vont trouver c'est le
symbole ggr un autre voilà une autre
personne ne voit la balle aux politiques
qui sont est odieux et insultants
permanence avec les journalistes sur
lequel il ne serait rien le jour où un
certain un journaliste très connu voilà
qui m'envoient ça qui m'a dit le jour on
le suivra plus il sera très malheureuse
voilà ce qu'il veut faciliter son qu'il
faut laisser à leurs hôtes et en leur
mairie c'est ce qui m'horripile c'est ce
que vous avez dit je suis désolée mais
voilà c'est mélenchon c'est lui c'est
comme ça c'est l'enfant terrible on lui
permet tout éveillé que sa partie
jusqu'au 6 mai aps l écharpe tricolore
tu dis pas l'arrêter
ouais les gars
cherry est ce que ça vous choque pas
lâcher une question qui fait qu'ils
émanent y parvient la briche à des
journalistes dans son parti voilà et qui
sont là pour filmer parce que c'est les
gens disent qu'ils filment et qui sont
en train de ballades fin des mecs ne
sont pas victimiser complot c'est
l'actors studio
alors ça les jeux mais aussi les
journalistes les journalistes jean luc
mélenchon s'est connecté éternellement
voilà tendu on a tous les autres jours
un rapport compliqué regarder ce jour là
et s'en prend à l'un d'entre eux et
c'est encore musclé ria 8 la raison tous
les politiques sont des prêtres nancy
s'y attend le club c'est parce qu'il est
d'ailleurs tous les hommes sont des
menteurs et toutes les femmes sont
détendus qu'est ce qui en général et
dans l'histoire et bretonnes sont ait pu
à temps quand on fait des produits
bretons sont têtus les corses avaient
squatté jamais revu mais vous qui je
suis moi mais caché dedans pour mettre
les gommes chargé de mettre dedans
pourquoi tu te passe toujours pas
pourquoi son nez de niro a donc j'ai
annoncé à mes questions délirante là non
je te dirai pas dire pose ta question
allez on va écouter la wimax et c'est là
un très fort c'est que en attendant on
parle pas des deux enquêtes
préliminaires dont il fait l'objet
bien sûr et c'est charles pasqua qui
disait il faut toujours allumé un
contre-feu c'est vrai je suis et donc
voilà alors très jacques vous pour vous
est ce que là ça va ça va être
préjudiciable pour jean luc mélenchon
oui c'est préjudiciable parce que c'est
à répétition d'accord ça finit par
lasser les gens et ça finit par par
finement altéré quand même cette
sincérité
à la fin il en fait un moyen de
communiquer alors affaire ben alaya une
perquisition des millions à se faire moi
je crois que dix mois ce que ça existe
chez les hommes je vais trop nerveux
peut-être que la ménopause
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas la première fois c'est pas la
première fois qu'il ya un homme
politique voilà qu'est les gars qui
dérape un peu on se rappelle bien sûr de
nicolas sarkozy c'est le 25 février 2010
et c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens qui
me disent vraiment sur twitter si ça
avait été nicolas sarkozy ça aurait été
un critère le mot contre lui c'était le
25 février 2008 le président de la
république se rendait au salon de
l'agriculture quand t'as pas cent ans
refuse de lui serrer la main
on se rappelle tous de cette image
sabine et casse-cou
[Musique]
sas avait été préjudiciable pour ça lui
a coûté l'élection c'est ça la seule
chose c'est un des marqueurs toujours
d'ailleurs de nicolas sarkozy et c'est
plusieurs dizaines peut-être centaines
de milliers de voix et xavier
discussions après les mots ouais c'était
à peine un an quand on représente la
france pour choisir ses mots ou alors il
ya dix ans le métier il ya dix ans il y
en a un il ya deux visions lionavec
hemming claque à un enfant d'un an et là
au contraire ils avaient été très très
bien perçue par les français regardent
minimum pendant la discussion quelques
enfants se masse autour du candidat
ouah
mais la cdu mack sennett est une scène
pour ça que ça s'arrache tout s'arrache
ou alors il y en a d'autres qui ont
perdu bahia rachida dati aussi alors
qu'elle discutait avec bruno gollnisch
député du front national a sorti du
parlement européen à strasbourg
racing rachida s'est senti piégé par la
caméra d'un journaliste qu'elle pensait
de l'équipe de yann barthès
sauf que eux et regardez elle s'emporte
un peu et c'est vrai qu'elle aussi voilà
c'est une image qui reste mais depuis
c'est rattraper voilà soyons qui avons
nous là rachida dati et le frontiste
bruno gollnisch keane donc cette voie là
bon ça n'a pas tellement marqué si un
autre truc voilà moi la vidéo voilà qui
me fait le plus voilà rires on l'avait
beaucoup fait avec notre ami bertrand
chamerois c'est jean marie le pen lors
de la commémoration de lait directement
à jeanne d'arc et total des voix que
instants après sa fille
ils rentrent à son tour hommage à jeanne
d'arc
à sa façon
alors on va la voir sa fille
ils rentrent à son tour hommage à jeanne
d'arc
à sa façon
[Applaudissements]
au score
mélenchon aussi qui lui c'est vraiment à
la tête avec un partisan du fn un jour à
ce que vous rappeler cet échange le ton
par très vite ils m'ont très vite très
haut le ton et comme d'habitude il fait
pas dans la dentelle
regardez moi monsieur vous êtes un gros
un beso je disais hé ouais mon bonheur
on peut pas être sénateurs et députés en
même temps vous avez un pois chiche à la
place du cerveau
alors je gagne 40 mille euros espèce
d'imbécile ouais ouais comment tu sais
vas-y le voir les uns traitants et c'est
tout ça on dirait mon nez comme ça les
deux coins pour la santé c'est
incroyable où il a dit non mais vous
êtes face à en plus ça c'est vrai que
c'est drôle moi ce que je ne pardonne
pas c'est hier l'attitude face aux
policiers parce que parce qu'en plus ils
sont on voit sur les images je les
admire parce qu'il reste a dit mme x ne
peuvent pas bouger parce que c'est
quelqu'un a évidemment que c'est un élu
mais là c'est vraiment indigne de sa
position et comment voulez vous qu'ils
prétendent ensuite à être peut-être
président de la république a chapeauté
le ministère de l'intérieur ces images
ressortiront toujours pour moi c'est
très très grave s'il savait très bien
edouard philippe
voilà mais voilà après différents
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors ils ont trouvé un bon moyen de le
faire taire à l'assemblée nationale jean
luc mélenchon puisque vous parlez de
voir philippe parler de ça bien sûr à
l'assemblée nationale et regarder
comment ça se passe avait inspiré tous
les fichiers du mouvement la france un
souvenir et qui ceux du parti de gauche
sans que nous ayons signé un seul procès
verbal collègues
êtes vous devenus déraisonnables
voyez-vous ce que ça veut dire vous
sentez-vous solidaire de procéder pareil
nous en est à hurler matin mais voulez
vous rendez plus content je n'ai plus
que la justice
ce n'est plus de la police va de la sfio
les motifs l'infâme or pour lesquelles
vous prétendez nouveaux amis de monsieur
le premier
[Rires]
marine le pen qui applaudit derrière ça
va être assez rare un aller chercher là
où il est pour moi c'est nominal c'est
que ont péri des lois non non c'est pas
elle doit donc c'était de la politique
c'est le personnage c'est l'appel au
peuple il court circuit tout je suis un
élu de la république le peuple est avec
moi vous n'avez pas tout changer du tout
d'ailleurs
et c est ça et ça ça touche les gens
mais c'est parce que tous on est on est
tous du peuple et ça mais pour moi c'est
là où ils vraiment les marchés qu'on a
fait marrer la marine le pen ce matin a
twitté en sa faveur
et puis je sais qu'elle a fait une
bêtise comme s'ils sont une immortelle
elle en français ah oui harry serait pas
bien sûr l as qu'elle a fait exprès
marine le pen de twitter la faveur de
jean-luc mélenchon
bien sûr tout de suite un cadeau aux
foyers il a fait part c'est un acte
politique
comment travailler moi je suis au dessus
de ça c'est moi qu'on dit la populiste
extrémiste c'est lui c'est pas moi est
exactement alors insérer que jean luc
mélenchon donc tout le monde en a parlé
aujourd'hui on va regarder votre le
sondage les politiques ont-ils le droit
de perdre leur salle zouaoui à 37% et
non à 63% je trouve que le oui est assez
élevé mais je pensais qu'ils seraient
penser qu'il se rende sous 1